this is Lucy James speaking for
Alessandra filari the opening hours of
Resident Evil 3 are incredibly effective
at putting you on edge
placing the volatile and intense
conflict between protagonist Jill
Valentine and the unrelenting force of
nature
the Nemesis front and center the remake
of the 1999 game presents some strong
survival horror moments that show off
the best of what the series can offer
but after that solid start it becomes
clear that this revisit to a bygone era
not only loses track of the type of
horror game that Resident Evil once was
but also loses sight of what made the
original so memorable
re3 is very much a companion piece to
resident evil' to serving as a
simultaneous prequel and sequel that
caps off the saga in Raccoon City the
remake of Resident Evil three interprets
the classic survival horror through a
modern lens redesigning locations and
altering key events to fit a
significantly revised story
it doesn't deviate too much from the
formula set by its predecessor but it
does have a more pronounced focus on
action horror returning protagonist Jill
Valentine is a capable survivor and
she's well suited to handle the undead
and other bioweapon monstrosities like
nemesis that roam the city along with
dodging attacks she can also pull off
slow-mo evasive roles that open a clean
shot at the enemy's weak point which can
be especially satisfying to pull off
during an intense encounter while this
ultimately gives you a greater feeling
of control in the field it's not enough
to the point where it makes these
encounters with the ravenous undead or
nemesis easy
ari 3s introduction is a strong one
conveying a creeping sense of paranoia
and dread that's synonymous with the
series and Jill Valentine once again
proves herself to be a confident
protagonist to take everything head-on
you'll eventually cross paths with
supporting characters like mercenary
Carlos La Vie era the game's second
playable character along with some other
unsavory individuals looking to take
advantage of the chaos for their own
ends the key players also get their own
big moments throughout the plot which
will earned and are fun to see play out
but disappointingly re3 story reaches
its conclusion after a brisk six hour
campaign which is made worse by a
lackluster finish that left me wanting
while this is comparable to the 1999
game the shrinking scope of the remix
campaign after its great opening makes
the short run all the more clear
still re3 possesses an impeccable level
of detail for the locations and action
during its brief campaign one of my
favorite areas of the game is set in
downtown Raccoon City which shows off
the best the remake has to offer as an
expansive map it not only presents
diverse locations packed with plenty of
undead it also displays the dynamic
nature of the game's true star the
Nemesis during these moments the game's
antagonist actively stalks and follows
you into places you want thought were
safe bending the unspoken rules of
engagement in survival horror to
establish its presence further nemesis
makes the tyrant from RE to come across
as a fedora wearing goon and even when
you find yourself in a safe space you
can catch a glimpse at the villain
waiting outside for you to leave which
still stands as some of the most
unnerving moments in the game however as
the game goes on it becomes clear that
Resident Evil three struggles to
maintain a good pace just when you're
getting accustomed to a location a story
beat will occur that will bring you to
the next area preventing your return
puzzles are also infrequent which puts
more of its focus on exploration and
combat that becomes a bit stale towards
the end of the game there are some
moments where the game strengths for
action and horror shine but generally
its attempts to balance both can come
across as hollow and at its worst they
can be jarring this is especially true
with the many elaborate set-piece
encounters where you control Jill as she
navigates uncharted liked sequences they
often result in tonal whiplash as you
typically transition back into the
slower survival horror pacing right
after this is the most evident in the
portrayal of the game's primary
antagonist nemesis is at its best when
stalking you in the streets but these
sections while terrifyingly engaging are
fleeting
in actuality Nemesis only actively hunts
you during the opening section in
downtown Raccoon City with other
encounters thereafter tied to scripted
sequences and boss fights the nemesis is
undoubtedly one of the most iconic
villains of the series and it's
frustrating to see how the remake locks
away one of the game's biggest assets
behind uninteresting and counters after
you finished the campaign Resident Evil
three opens up a bonus shop in the main
menu that lets you purchase new costumes
and extra items with credits gained
from completing challenges while these
can be fun for a revisit there isn't
much else in the way of bonus content to
keep you going also included with the
remake is resident evil resistance an
asymmetrical online mode pitting for
survivors against a lone player in the
role of the overseeing antagonist in
essence it's a more accessible take on
the franchise's previous experiment with
online horror Resident Evil Outbreak
with some echoes of other asymmetrical
games like dead by daylight or left for
dead playing as the survivors feels
closer to traditional Resident Evil
where resources are scarce and the
stakes become increasingly more
significant using each survivors skills
effectively can come in clutch during
into fight saving you and your team from
the masterminds tactics resistance has
interesting ideas when it comes to
bringing the series survival horror game
play online and does an adequate job of
getting you up to speed with solid
tutorials yet the overall execution of
the games mechanics often comes off as
clunky and undercooked the controls for
the survivors feel unresponsive
especially when trying to get a clean
hit on fast-moving targets resistance
also lacks a personality of its own
while each survivor has a backstory they
mostly pull on horror movie cliches and
archetypes and they rarely speak during
the actual game which can make it hard
to connect with them the most fun to be
had in resistance is playing as the
mastermind where you can see the
survival horror game play play out from
the other side some of the most
satisfying moments come from whittling
down the defences of the survivors and
snatching away their last vestiges of
hope as they attempt their final escape
at its best it's a clever real-time
strategy twist on the survival horror
formula but generally the games already
clunky gameplay gets in the way
resistance didn't hold my attention long
and while Resident Evil 3 is the
stronger of the two
it's still disappointing looking back on
my first playthrough of the re 3 remake
it was clear that the game reached its
peak early and slowly lost momentum
going forward when looking at the
remakes shortcomings it's difficult not
to think back to the original game while
this won't mean much for newcomers it is
still apparent that the shrinking scale
of the game diminishes the impact of its
plot and events as a remake Resident
Evil three not only falls short of
honoring its source but it also doesn't
quite stick the landing
when offering a solid standalone horror
experience even without taking into
account the original game or even its
predecessor our e3 struggles to keep up
with its pace amid a clashing of
elements from survival horror and
standard action it actively tries to
have both in conflicting ways and
doesn't succeed as well as it could have
with either while it has a strong start
and gives its principal villain some
great moments this truncated retelling
of the concluding game from the original
Resident Evil trilogy doesn't do a
proper justice